meantime southern nevada experiencing a
blood shortage and the american red
cross needs your help
one of the main causes is pandemic
strain christian cassidos joining us now
live in the newsroom to tell us how
severe this need is
christian well denise the american red
cross says the low level of blood is
severe and they're trying to be
proactive to avoid running out now we
all know blood
cannot be stockpiled so the need as you
can imagine is
consistent now the american red cross
has seen a significant
increase since 2019 about a 10
climb in blood transfusions that
includes er patients organ patients and
surgeries among other causes
they tell us the pandemic has also
increased the demand now during the
month of june they are also reminding
the community
that donating blood once you recover
from the covet 19 virus
is also important a single blood
donation they say
can save lives the american red cross
has delivered about 75 000
blood products in the last three months
which has been you know a little bit
unexpected for us
so we are depending on those eligible
blood donors
to give blood to make a meaningful
impact
all right there are several
opportunities to donate blood starting
today through june 30th
we have a complete list of all the
locations and the link to book your
appointment on our website right now
8newsnow.com now remember to be eligible
to donate blood you have to be
healthy you have to be 110 pounds or
heavier and
be 17 years of age or older a quick and
simple process
can literally save someone's life
christian cassette is 8 news now